my lovely genius brain farts this
podcast is brought to you by fume what
is fume you ask fume it's an
award-winning flavored air device that
gives you a better way to break your bad
habits your fume comes with an
adjustable air flow dial and is designed
with movable parts and magnets for
fidgeting giving your fingers a lot to
do which is helpful for de-stressing and
anxiety while breaking your bad habit my
friends and I'm talking about I use this
in the car and I start clicking away and
puffing at that thing and it helps me
de-stress I love it start the holidays
off right with the good habit by going
to trium.vira and getting the journey
packed today few's giving listeners of
the show 10% off when they use my code
genius to help make starting the good
habit that much easier start the good
habit at tri.com genius to save 10% off
the journey pack today my lovely genius
brain fars this podcast is brought to
you by mintmobile give yourself the gift
of insane savings this holiday season
with M Mobile's best wireless deal of
the year right now when you switch to
mmobile and buy any 3 Monon plan you'll
get another 3 months for free ooh I'm
not playing around and think about all
the stuff you could do with those
savings like buy that hot day
a meal outside of just those quick fast
food joints o you going to look good and
maybe guess what she might give you a
little something something after or he
who knows by selling online and limiting
the traditional cost of retail mmobile
passes significant savings on to you so
for a limited time by any 3-month
mmobile plan and get 3 months for free
by going to mobile.com genius5 that's
mobile.com genius5 new customers only
additional taxes fees and restrictions
apply see mmobile for details family
here he was cool as hell we don't trust
none of we was in Africa the blackest
place I ever been I don't trust this
[__]
I'm we walking with our
friends cool 543 21 what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we we of course already
have the dorm tment boys here today
minus a few members but uh if you
checked out on the last podcast we were
talking a lot about traveling and stuff
like that but one of the fun things that
people do when they travel what I found
out was they'll go on like uh uh like
hinge and [__] and they have that
internationally so when my friends would
go to like Japan or Asia or Europe they
would just open up the dating app and
they said it's the most fun thing on
Earth because people are they want to
date like foreign people yeah right have
you guys ever done like a a trip to like
Europe and stuff too yeah we went to
Greece o how was that one of the most
beautiful places I've abely it looks
like painting but it also was during the
pandemic so the first three days we got
there like all the night life was shut
down and then the last like three days
it opened up so but there was how many
countries have you guys been to so far
been through Africa too I'm trying to
think Dam you guys traveled that much
okay we can just
okay and we're late bloomers too that's
what I'm saying this kind of like this
onset of traveling happened later in
life for you yeah if you want to we can
go through and I can tell you layovers
too okay so Greece layover was in
London cool next was synagog Leo
was in Paris and yep and then we came
back next was headed
to Tania the layover was in uh Amsterdam
and we had two and oh that was San Fran
so that don't count Amsterdam Amsterdam
then we went from Tanzania to Egypt but
the layup so Egypt what right quick
Amsterdam random story so we're in the
lounge and we're just chilling Rome goes
to take a shower so I'm just chilling
out there sound so
Bouie a shower in loung I'm just
chilling on my computer and Rome said
where you at I tell him so I'm back on
my computer and then Rome's like yo cam
I'm like yeah he like look up I look up
and I'm talking about if I'm sitting
right here literally right here Louis CK
is staring me right in my eye get the
[__] out of here Lou CK is standing
right in front of me and looking at me
so now I'm looking at him cuz I'm like
confused like L CK he's looking at me
and then he's looking we're looking then
he just walks off and I'm like
random it was so [__] random what the
hell and he just walked off and I still
to this day like I don't know what that
was about do you know me or do we met
maybe it like the Japanese lady
thought he was like you know me you know
you I was hot and I K you in that
corner like I do know you but I don't
know you maybe he sens that you were
American immediately I mean I mean it
was a lot cuz it was him and then Rome
was like standing right here so I'm like
I don't know what was going on it was
damn that's random as [__] random as
hell we went in Tanzania in my bad you
know this was like kind of after he got
a little cancelled so you haven't seen
him in so in a minute yeah yeah so it
was just random that's some odd timing
it was yeah it was very very random got
canceled to another country that's crazy
Tanzania we went to Ethiopia layover on
the way to Egypt and I purposely picked
that CU I love Ethiopian food want to
have it Egypt hottest place we ever been
to in our life straight up desert we
went July it was ridiculous my least
favorite place Place we've been thus far
oh Egypt yeah good for the pyramid not
like it's this terrible place to go but
out of everywhere you have a r system of
what you like pyramids and seeing the
mummy amazing that's but it's really
restrictive there like you have to sign
in everywhere you go like you got to go
with a guide most places like when you
go there police you sign in they know
your whereabouts I guess that's how they
keep you safe but it was just like too
restricted for me and then outside the
Pyramids in Cairo at least we only went
to Cairo we was only there for a couple
days but outside that in the museum you
know freak me the [__] out like I when
you see it in person it's crazy CU it's
just like none of it makes sense to me
how how did they do this exactly so
logically it doesn't make sense to me
there's dead people here I don't
understand and when you and it's only
the the biggest one that we've seen in
CYO was built for one tomb not it was
one one tomb in there and and then what
you don't know unless you're doing
really research that the the wives are
behind that big pyramid and their
pyramids are small and it looks so funny
like I didn't want to laugh I had to
laugh cuz I was just so shocked when the
guy he was like this is for the king and
he's and he was like oh and they're
wives and it l like when I die keep that
[__]
away but yeah I didn't want to go inside
I was like I respect I don't want to go
inside but I had to touch it it was like
that was on my bucket list to touch that
like and then we went uh Egypt Morocco
layover and then but I forgot to say
when we Greece coming back we had a lay
over in Madrid your passport must be
[__] insane it's the you know it's
getting there trying to trying to and
then we come back and then next was Bali
you forgot about Madrid happened in
Madrid but what happened in Madrid oh uh
I made a mistake goof this time and I
was looking at I thought the flight time
was 12 hours that was The Layover so I
accidentally booked the the the flight
with the layover in Madrid for 12 hours
and what made it even worse is we landed
like at 1:00 in the morning pic time so
everything is like closed and we like
like we'll we'll do a in in airport
hotel but the only problem with that it
was outside the gate it was right there
but this the pandemic we can't risk not
being able to get back in without tests
and all this you had to stay there so we
had to stay there So eventually we find
this empty Burger King we like we just
going to sleep here so I guess I don't
know maybe an hour all I feel a nudge
and the cleaner's like we got to clean
here y'all got to go so we got kicked
out the Burger King we sleeping on the
on the [__] I told you we have it our
way
going on
tweeted you li where's the king yeah
yeah so then we came back and then the
next was uh Bali which The Layover um
was in Korea and then B Thailand I'll
tell you what happened in Korea Korea
Airline made me mad but I was so happy
about the country I let let it slide
something I'm there got my ticket we in
the lounge uh representative calls my
phone and I'm like this is a Korean
number like hello they was like uh where
are you right now I'm like who's this
what he I'm and she tell me I'm a
representative I need to come talk to
you so I tell them in the lounge so then
they come to the lounge she like uh your
ticket is not paid for what you mean I
Got My Ticket email confirmation it is
paid for she like yeah but we don't
charge you until I forgot some silly
stuff like they don't charge you you
know they just reserve it I guess when
you put so I had to go check my bank
account and it really didn't it didn't
charge me which is on their end but you
think you paid cuz I got the email
confirmation I got all the paperwork
with me so luckily I had the money on me
and I had to pay right then and there
that would but that would have been bad
like if he had already spent the money
you know or cuz I'm thinking I already
did so I was about to spend some money
so it was just like yeah that that made
me mad but it worked out um yeah and
then so then Japan was the last place I
went to uh biz for my birthday um you
did a little solo trip yeah went to biz
I can't do solo trips man and I did a
solo trip before Japan I went to Dubai
and Abu Dhabi I visit a friend stay with
a friend and that was that place crazy
what does it like doing solo trips right
cuz I can't do it like I like traveling
at least with one other person cuz I
like experiencing things together with
people so sometimes like doing things on
my own it's cool right but it's just a
little different when you just have one
person I think you have to go for a long
time I think if you go for a solo trip
like you could even do like I would say
plan it if it's somewhere maybe you know
somebody and then take like maybe two
days to yourself or something like that
you don't have to do the whole that was
me when I went to Dubai my home girl
says in Abu Dhabi so I landed in Dubai
like I was there for like who the [__]
do you know in Abu Dhabi I know people
everywhere I got know people everywhere
kids everywhere too don't gots in all of
cams walk but what I did it was like
certain things I want to do like we were
supposed to maybe Skydive but she
actually wanted to say that money going
another trip so we canceled that but I
wanted to do the desert all the desert
stuff in Dubai so I booked a tour from
the hotel buddy came and picked me up
and I told Rome like hey this where I'm
going case I'm happen I'm going to the
middle of the desert get to the desert
luckily it was a holiday nobody else
there but me so I had the whole track I
put a real of that we did the sand dunes
we drove the 4x4s I I drove the the Doom
buggies insane Road a camel I don't like
riding camels they seem so sad I I I
hate when you they just look like they
got a bunch of attitude that's why I
like them dude too much sad the way they
chew to but that's another city that's
super clean and orderly like you there's
no homeless people there you have to be
working hurt cuz like if you do you just
die there like real consequence there's
a guy who was like in Abu Dhabi or Dubai
and he was like this is my Rolls-Royce
I'm going to leave my my key fob on here
and watch I'm going to the gym I come
back car's still here and everybody who
lives there they're like yeah cuz if we
stole it we would have our hands chopped
off There's real consequences here my
home girl so that stays in Abu Dhabi she
said one day she called me she like you
won't believe what just happened I'm
like what she like I was coming back
from a night out with friends I'm
walking it was this guy kind of like out
there but you know it's real safe in Abu
Dhabi so she had her building and she
said while she's walking to the thing
she looks back while she's going in the
door she space up cuz he's like getting
closer she closed the door looks back
he's jerking off so immediately she goes
to security she says soon as she told
security to took off running say where
took off running and the other on start
locating them on the camera So
eventually they found out where he stay
he stays in the other building went
there he's either deported or in jail
that's crazy don't [__] around they
don't play I guess you could say she was
getting
hijacked this
[__] the Dubai Mall the Dubai
Mall is the biggest mall I ever been to
ro Chas her down to tell the joke wait
wait you getting hij jacked get your ass
out here
it was the biggest yeah it was the
biggest mall I ever been to I got lost
three times it got to the point I just
saw light and I said I'm going to exit
here I can't find out I can't find where
I
came I couldn't find where I came in
like I'm great with directions too big
of a mall I think the biggest thing we
do when we travel we make sure we do
things you know some people travel and
they just do like the very touristy
thing like we we did hot air balloon and
the over the sing gy we spent the night
in the S and gy like we did all typ like
in a tent in a tent that was crazy
that's crazy I don't know like a hot air
balloon I'm scared of heights like a
[__] there was a that's funny
you say that look there was a lady she
been putting it off for 10 years her
husband was like come on and she was
just so nervous she was in the basket
behind it so nervous soon as we got up
there she was like what was I scared of
it was so peaceful and calm like like if
I'm go out here I'm not even let me tell
you something man I got some of the
worst luck on Earth anything that has
that can happen terrible has happened to
me I'mma be in that hot air balloon and
an eagle is going to fly right through
that [__] and it's just going to start
falling down immediately and you going
to see me on the [__] news I already
know I'm just so scared my Palms are
sweating right now tell him about how
how it works
the so when we get up there the the dude
flying and he's like uh we don't know
where we're going to land yet there's no
way to control where we're going he's
like I can go up I can releas to come
down but we'll go where we go so then
he's going to find a landing spot and
the whole time the trucks are following
us so yeah so when we decide he like
okay we found the spot we go land here
and when we land there the truck's
pulled up pop some champagne he didn't
want to land where like no crazy cuz we
over to Taran GTI so he don't want to
land where lions are so he found a
little zebra patch we flew over Pride
Rock though it looks just like Pride
Rock typ [__] elephants why would you do
this it was just so beautiful though it
that is [__] crazy every chance I get
if I was doing this and then my guy told
me I don't know where we are going to go
I would be so pissed in I'm like what
the [__] are you talking about too late
now I don't care it's too late it's just
like what makes it worse is he was an
Australian white man so he really could
he could took he take
anywhere where we
going that's the craziest thing I've
ever heard in my life man it it was wild
well you guys can be in a hot air
balloon and look down and not freak the
[__] out no it was
was that why you Skydive too man you
could just die any second you don't
[__] know are you insane I saw I saw
a Skydive thing where the [__] lady's
parachute didn't [__] deploy and
happen oh I saw this video skydiving
plane for some [__] reason another
plane crashed into the other plane they
all survived though [__] I don't give a
[__] here's the thing I was down to do
it did I ever tell you the story about
skyd no okay so the re the way I did it
I always wanted to do it but this was in
college so a home girl said hey for my
birthday I'm inviting all my friends to
skydive she said 20 people said yes
showed up so I like all right bet I'm
I'm in I want to do this day of three
people show up one of them is the
birthday girl and one of them's me and
one's a manual so then I'm like oh four
sorry another guy so I said I'm doing
this I'm here so we go they give all the
instructions they say you know this is
the main parachute if that don't go
here's the backup parachute shoot and
they showing you what to do you know
everything so then we get in the plane
and you're connected to a person so
you're basically we all like a centipede
I'm sitting down and the dude sitting
down his legs are cuz I'm basically
attached to him so then the people that
jump by themselves they go first and I
was like I'm going first cuz I want to
be waiting and all the anxiety so then
we get to the edge of the door he's like
all right we're going to jump on three
I'mma count us down like all right so he
does one two he jumps I said you son
mother we going down it's like 10 15
seconds you just going and then he he
pulls the shoot as soon as he pulls the
shoot and you see it you just feel at
peace it's like I survived the toughest
part that's all you waiting on so now we
just we just talking and I noticed like
my restraint is really in my nuts so I'm
like can we loosen this a tad bit cuz we
got about 15 20 minutes till we get down
so he started loosening he like
something more I said no no no no just
in case no no no that's it cuz I don't
want you to accidentally not drop out
but he asked me the one thing he asked
before he he said do you want to pull
the shoot I said no I don't want to mess
this up but after that you know you you
you let you you know maneuver a little
bit and then the last question he ask do
you want to run in or slide in I like I
got bad knees let me slide in so I slid
in so I said all right I did it I said
if I ever do it again it'll be in Dubai
so when my home girl say she want to do
it I said I'll do it with you you know
where you want to do it then I heard a
lot of people a lot of my friends did
this anyways people love doing it Hawaii
that's what I heard yeah you get to see
the whole ocean you get to see all of
Hawaii and then you just float into your
I don't need to do it no more I did it
it is scary but it's a it's amazing
about the ocean if we get a good gust of
wind and go over somewhere in the ocean
I'm like [__] hey let me tell you
something man like the ocean is one of
the no that's one of the scarest I love
swimming right but you got to understand
like in the ocean when I swim I look
like a seal that's that's done like
that's it that's it like did they see me
it's just the same [__] I not I'm not
even [__] lying I was in Hawaii and I
was swimming at this uh snorkeling spot
right and I felt this uh Shadow next to
me I turned around and it was a [__]
seal like this close to my [__] face
and cuz I thought it was a shark and I
freaked the [__] out and it just kept
swimming around me and I looked up and
there was another dude he goes I've
never seen a monal come that close to a
human before I was like I think he
thought I was him and that [__] highy
pissed me off I was like a little
offended he said bro I'm I'm oh I love
swimming in I love going snorkeling but
not where great whites live so like Cali
Hawaii South Africa all them places I am
good you just got to stay close to like
the coral area and you'll be fine once
you start going like deeper then you'll
see stuff like people like my buddies
went uh shark cage diving and [__] I'm
good off of that [__] dude when I when I
realized the ocean was huge when we were
coming back from Korea to La it's a
10-hour flight it's nothing but ocean
but the fact that really blew my mind
I'm looking out the window I'm like wait
we're going 600 mph and it's still
taking 10 hours that's a lot of water
yes if you get lost out here you are
it's it's a it's a wrap you know here's
the thing like I sometimes just be
thinking about crazy [__] and because
I'm so scared of heights I was very
scared of getting on planes and like the
only way that I kind of like calm my
nerves now I know this sounds a little
crazy I was like look if I die all you
[__] dying with me I
mean I don't give a [__] surv so we all
die together [__] it but then I I
started watching shows like lost and
stuff and I kept thinking like could I
survive if if we landed in an island
could I [__] survive and I don't know
if I can I think that's the only place I
have a small chance anywhere else no but
Island since I'm beham I've been on
Islands so much like and been with Dad
climbing trees getting stuff I know
that's not the most survival skills but
I think that's the only place I will be
might be have some type of confidence
this is the only thing that like if you
go down in the middle of whatever only
thing is you like what's on this cuz if
especially if it's a place that nobody's
ever explored like what the [__] is on I
just wanty you want no try like no you
don't know what's on that's the only
part you're like I hope it ain't No
Nonsense I'm always scared too it's like
I always think about like if you're with
a group of people you know everybody's
always going to look at the fat person
to try to kill him we just got the most
[__] nutrition on us it's always get
so scared just like what the [__] are
you thinking about right now you see
somebody smacking their lips and [__] I
just read a book and then book it was
talking about this guy that was got they
got 10 people got stuck on Mount Everest
and the airplane crashed it was like oh
no I think they were they actually hyped
but it's some crazy storm coming oh they
they were climbing on purpose yeah idiot
and then I'm with that I'm not with the
is what his wife and and kid was with
him I think his wife and kid died
everybody else started dying if a few of
them started surviving but they started
surviving they had to they had to eat
like the the people oh [__] genius brain
listeners this podcast is brought to you
by Zach doc have you ever been on the
hunt for a new doctor and you ask
literally everyone you know for their
Reco so you call their office they have
an appointment available but then the
reception tells you this perfect doctor
doesn't take your insurance what the
heck is going on we wipe your tears put
away the ice cream and head over Zach
duck to find and book the Doctor Who is
right for you and takes your Insurance
there's a lot of weird Cooks out there
that want to give you advice about your
health but they don't know absolutely
nothing well with Zach do you can you
can find that doctor who actually has
amazing reviews with many appointments
available within 24 hours Z talk is a
free app my friends free app where you
can find amazing doctors and book
appointments online we're talking about
booking appointments with thousands of
top rated patient reviewed doctors and
Specialists you can filter specifically
for ones who take your insurance or
located near you treat almost any
condition you're searching for so go to
Zach do.com genius and download the Zach
do app for free then find and book a
toprated doctor today that's cd.com
genius Zach do.com genius genius brain
listeners this podcast is brought to you
by fume listen cold turkey may be great
on sandwiches but there's a better way
to break your bad habits and we're not
talking about some weird mind voodoo
from your crazy neighbor you ever have
those people who tell you all the
solutions to a problem that they don't
know what the they're talking about yeah
we're not talking about that we're
talking about fume now what is fume you
ask fume is an award-winning flavored
air device that gives you a better way
to break your bad habits your fume comes
with an adjustable airflow dial and it's
design with movable parts and magnets
for fidgeting giving your fingers a lot
to do which is helpful for de-stressing
anxiety while breaking your habit so
start the holidays off- right with the
good habit by going to trif nume.com
genius and get the journey pack today
fume is giving listeners of the show 10%
off when they use my code genius to help
make starting the good habit that much
easier start the goodh Habit at
trium.vira
make it but he said I I can't eat my
wife and kids and so they ended up they
ended up it was a crazy story they ended
up going they finally found somebody and
was able to say the rest of the people
but I'm like that's a tough position to
be in like oh I would have ate the [__]
out of her your wife got to go your wife
got to go baby I've been eating you
already I thought 30 minutes
in you eat the but in
vagina I think you know I think two lips
can hold me over about two days I can
feel like a pile of snacks I just push
it aside like you know I do like fish
I'm
pescatarian but the funny thing about
like Will Smith said the best things in
life on the other side of fear so all
the scary stuff I've done have been the
most beautiful experiences the hot air
balloon the sky diving but like one that
kept me was a great whites I never
surfed before I'm like you people always
surf out here but I'm like I'm not
getting bit it's not worth it so when we
went to Bali they had surfing they like
yeah there's no sharks here and a sand
bottom so I'm like all right let me try
it it was one of the most fun things
I've ever done I get it I say I say I
get it surfing white guys I understand
you know where I said anything bad that
could happen does happen to me I went
surfing surfboard flew off of somebody
smashed my nose into
pieces and I was in Hawaii damn and I'm
over here just recording this is kind of
cool I'm like damn that board's kind of
coming
fast and then you there's like a
recording of me and then you just hear
me in the water going oh what the [__]
to do stuff with you my whole [__]
eyes are bruising so we got to stay away
from
David we just go to eat with David just
eat but the thing is like no bad thing
happens to other people I just take all
the bad juju so you guys will just maybe
we be good mayy bring you with us it's a
shark oh never mind he going to David D
you just see me just be
Dr damn that's crazy but I always
survive I don't [__] know how but I
always get [__] up there was a similar
story too where there was a plane that
crashed on a mountain side and it was I
think a majority of people did
survive and they had to slowly
cannibalize and eat everybody there man
and so they had to keep sending people
out to go find help and I guess like
they were kind of at their wits end at
this point nothing they could do so I
forgot who it was that went out and they
actually [__] found help and they
treed over mountains yeah to go find
civilization we might be talk it could
be the same story it could disting it
could have been but it's it's tough cuz
it's just like it's hard that's how I
look at it but maybe it's so hard to
judge a person if you had not been that
hungry cuz imagine the amount of hunger
you have to be and thinking about
surviving did have to do lunch and I
look at my wife that way so you know and
and it's like if you don't have a fire
are you just you just raw you're raw
dogging you raw eating well this is the
thing too like after they went to town
and they they they rescued everybody
else they found out that they ate people
The Whole Town's like turned on them
they call monster
like but you you were never in that
situation you have no idea what I'm
going through I don't know what's and if
they didn't do that and by the way they
were eating the people who had already
died they've already deceased they
weren't murdering them it was just there
and they're like okay we have to survive
so they yeah I heard like the the people
who survived they were just [__] on
them calling them monsters and creatures
but you weren't in that situation
exactly you got to go with the medious
part first so uh I'm had to eat some
butt
bro I I got to take a little cheek off I
just got to taste for Human After
constantly just everybody's walking by
like God you get mad when you find out
it a
BBL process processed food right
there cuz all these
chemicals help you know what's so trippy
man like whenever whenever I go to
[__] Florida right Miami that's this
it's very seldom I'll never like take
off my shirt at a beach I don't give a
[__] what I look like Miami I always
keep my shirt on cuz everybody is
[__] Immaculate out there they're on
steroids buff as [__] bbl's everywhere I
never felt like a piece of [__] so much
in my life except for Miami why is
everybody so [__] just the funny
thing cuz you know I'm from Miami so I
think Miami prepared me for Europe
beaches because oh they Miami is the
only place I know where people just be
topless it's out it's not a new beach it
just be topless and it's whatever men
men being Speedos and stuff so when we
went to Europe it be full on naked old
men kids women just naked it's just like
it's so normal after a while you just
don't even think about it cuz here you
don't see that yeah you know everyone's
clothed but there is is so free in
Europe let me tell you the wildest thing
when we was in Greece this is how I know
I can never Rob anybody if I robed
somebody I would have to be silent I
couldn't use my voice we walking in the
middle of Greece we walking and this
pandemic so we got mask on and me and
him are talking we walk past this dud
dude all of a sudden I hear
Rome I
said yeah he was like oh man I knew I
recognize your voice I said that's crazy
that's crazy bro we in middle of Europe
somewhere he was like Rome and he was
like oh yeah I'm a fan I was like that
is scary I can never Rob anybody and say
anything it's loud vo people that
happened to me in Japan we were in uh
Shibuya and it's [__] sh there a lot
of people a lot of people especially at
the Crossing dog loud as [__] walking by
like David so they're like how' you know
it's me he like I recognize your voice
I'm like how how I was I wasn't even
saying I was thinking
words d fusive as [__] crazy that's the
same thing that seal said
David I recognize you iing suck that
still up that sh was so offensive
[__] stopped for a second like
damn your lims are different than
mine that [__] was and dog it's weird
like when you see creatures in water and
it's their element you feel feel
helpless yeah cuzz they flowing they're
[__] doing you ain't out swimming it
motherucker circling me and [__] that's
SC that's a little scary and so I'm like
oh what the [__] do I do if he decided
to attack you it's it's over it's done
oh he going to [__] me I don't know
which either way I'm pretty much done
dude I got seal dick inside me seal dick
that [__] [__] weird man what's the
next place you guys going to go to so
Brazil is Brazil dude super excited I
get scared of Brazil too man there's all
these South American countries that
scare the [__] out of no sou South
America you can't you got to be more
cautious cuz like you know Tokyo is
super safe and stuff so when I was
hanging out with my home girl we were
walking out alleys never felt yeah it's
a super sa but Brazil no let me tell you
something I seen a clip CU everybody
know prostitution is literally
everywhere especially in South America
Colombia this guy was in Colombia he is
insane he did a clip and it was uhe the
the title of it was like uh your dick
and make you do things that you took me
plac he said he said my dick has taken
me places I wouldn't go with a
gun and so he's you see him in a car
he's filming this he said uh yeah met a
girl going four hours out to her play
met girl on Tinder going 4 hours out in
colia don't speak the language I'm like
you're insane in a taxi for so I guess
he gets there he's showing the house bro
trap house it is you looking like like
what is this then he shows him coming
back he says um I'm playing music her
cousin her cousin taking me back I'm
playing music just so he can know that
we friends I'm playing music and I guess
survive but that is insanity I'm
not I'm never doing you could got there
she not there anything how you getting
they cut you up and and never going to
find you yeah they never going to yeah
there was these girls years ago who went
to South America and they were kind of
you know it's like the the the party
white girl right and it's just just like
the American what we were talking about
where America feels that everybody has
to follow our footsteps guess what
that's not how it [__] works so when
they were in South America you guys
probably look this up online they they
were warned by the people in the village
like hey you guys are women here like
it's dangerous yeah don't be going yeah
don't go [__] anywhere well these
women got kidnapped and they got like
brutally like murdered and like
assaulted and then you know when it
first came out and we talked about this
on JK news and I was basically saying
like listen the world doesn't fall to to
to your footsteps like the beat of your
drum if people there are telling you
like this is like well this is wrong
that's how men treat women I was like
that's all American [__] amican that's
over there
you took your American ideals and you
went there and you got [__] killed
what were you thinking you know and then
people didn't understand that they're
like oh you're a victim blaming I'm not
victim [__] blaming I'm saying like
I'm stupid blaming stupid that's not
smart that's not smart at all if I was
out there [__] cheed up they would
have [__] me too but even as a man
when I travel I never say I'm alone like
when when I was in Dubai and he like oh
who you with I'm here with friends and
the whole drive I'm tell him yeah I'm
meetting up with my friend today I'm
going to Abu Dhabi today told soon as
I'm and me the tri I'm let him he got
people are looking here they going to be
don't try no
[__] here Lu he was cool as hell we
don't trust none of that we was in
Africa the blackest place I ever been I
don't trust this [__]
I'm we walking with our friends and we
she was trying to take us to a party and
we look and she turned she like oh yeah
the party down here at the end we look
down there it's dark no I'm not going
down there [__] you talking I'm not
going down there we see a dog just
sitting down there oh [__] that no one
light and a dog even for the dog I'm not
going down the dog turn not doing I
don't go down places in California like
I'm not no I'm not playing with that cuz
these countries don't they don't give a
[__] like they're like I don't care who
supposed to go to a wedding in zakas in
Mexico right near Mexico I think that's
near Mexico City but the way that sounds
sounds like it's typed
zakas has a resort there right it's
supposed to be really beautiful we're
about to go 3 days before bunch of Tours
got kidnapped and killed and I'm like
guess what I'm doing canceling my
[__] [__] abolutely so we looked up
on like the government site they're like
do not go to zakas like we're not going
but it kind of sucked because I I think
like my wife's friend was kind of pissed
at her it's like you're not coming to my
wedding it's like you went to a [__]
were you insane you don't have to be mad
you got to be mad sorry
and like the people who went there they
were some of them were Mexican and some
of them didn't look they looked Mexican
like you guys are probably okay I'm
Googy as [__] like they're going to know
and guess who are the people who got
murdered and kidnapped it was actually I
think it was a group of like black
people like black Americans they're the
ones that got kidnapped and then
murdered and then the the cartel was
like oh we're sorry we won't do it again
likeo the sketchiest thing we did
sketchiest thing we did was Sagal so
we're taking a road trip and we're there
with someone who sagales so that's makes
a little more that's the only reason we
did this so we're going to this thing
called the pink lake and it's a lake
that's pink so we like let's go so we
driving following GPS GPS has turned
here so when we look it's like a a a
village like a community so got be right
on the other side or we
like uh all right let's go a little bit
and see when we get in there we're just
going deeper into a community and it's
like getting tight where it's like the
houses right here yeah and I'm like if
it was just me and you wrong we turning
back she know the language and it don't
seem dangerous but it's just like we off
the road we in a village now so then we
get to this point where it's just a
opening and it's just sand and it looked
like it could be like quick sand but we
got to pass this point to get to the
part where you can see we can't go back
now yeah where we can see we can drive
again so we sit there 10 minutes just
talking like trying to figure out like
should we do this and if we do do this
how do we do this I like obviously we
got to pick up speed we can't just roll
over we got to come back up and pick up
speed and go and 10 minutes we just
sitting there we like all right let's do
it so we back up we pick up speed and we
going it's bumping like just keep going
keep going and then we finally get
through it and we go through more
community and finally we get out but
luckily it was all
good never do that without her being
there and I would never do that and no
offense to anyone South America
somewhere was like it's just not people
in South America know too
like do that meone that or other parts
that's just a little more D but it
didn't seem but it was just like we in
the middle of a
village did y'all ever in a in a Range
Rover yeah in a Range Rover that made it
even worse I always wondered too did
y'all ever experience like any type of
like racism when you guys travel cuz
I've I've experienced it in like Mexico
they're they're so Brazen with their
Asian race it makes me laugh super hard
like you just walk out they just go ja
I'm like God damn we experienced that
cuz I'm about to say the only racism I
exper the one I'm giving out like when
I'm in Africa I see a white person like
get out here get out here now you see
how I feel get out here I see Wills out
there Wills get out of get out what are
you doing out of here Wills trying to
look for a [__] wife get the [__] out
of here our our our racism we experien I
would assume is like the I guess the
ignorant side of not knowing it's not
like purposeful but they Will Smith
Obama when they trying to sell me
something something like that like they
just say the most famous black person
but nothing like overt like straight up
in China they'll do that a lot like they
like the biggest thing that I always
heard when a when like some couple of
the homies who went there they always
call you uh like Jordan or
Kobe 100% cuz they're the most iconic
black people I'm not at all they're like
oh Kobe Kobe Kobe Kobe Kobe and they cuz
they love [__] Kobe Bryant and they
love Michael Jordan so they'll say that
like when I was cuz I did mission trips
and this I didn't go for fun this was
like missionary trips I a bunch of like
poor [__] but I moment moment I land
Jackie J like that's bold as
[__] but what you going to
do got I got asked for a picture in Bali
and I got mad after cuz I said no cuz it
was weird CU we were just talking about
it was just so weird like picture
picture picture and it just it just come
I like no I'm good but it wasn't balones
it was like Chinese it was like they we
was at a tour spot thinking that you
might be a celebrity and I got mad CU I
like I could have charged
them s like the next
person not a Chinese person they pay for
[__] they had on designer too so they
had money I could you want me to pay
I'll do it for 100 I go back to my
country I make a five of you right now
I'll do it for 100 yeah but now we
haven't experienced nothing nothing
crazy I feel like when when sometimes
when I see other like travel people they
speak about their racist situations and
it kind of more comes off as not hateful
it's just they're ignorant they don't
know they haven't seen you seen so it's
just like a new thing like I I had a
friend who came from Korea years ago
when I was like in third grade a
koreanid this [__] every time he
saw one black person he would freak the
[__] out like he just it was amazing to
him he's like oh my God there's [__]
black people here so he would like come
up and he would TR pinch like black
people and [__] I'm like hey yo
chill we not trying to get beat up I
just want to know if it's different cuz
he's just never it's different for us I
think it's a respect thing too like when
I go to a country I'm trying to learn
the basics hi thank you and like I'm
really trying to be in your culture and
respect your culture I look up the rules
so I don't offend like in Bali they have
offerings everywhere and they say don't
step on
those try not to so I come with respect
so I feel like when they see you trying
to be respectful that they appreciate it
for sure right cuz I know for me like
when when I go to places too biggest pet
peeve is so this is what I was talking
about traveling with people that you
[__] with is very [__] important and
I travel with this one girl who [__]
annoy the [__] out of me cuz she was in
Japan and she just wasn't with what the
Japanese stuff was like being quiet not
eating while you're walking and [__] and
she was I don't give a [__] and she was
doing that that [__] got like I hate
people like my blood boil I was like dog
why the [__] do you come here cuz it's
not even it's not even that serious
these are small things like it's not
even as serious yeah it's like like you
know you conversely too when people come
over here and they start doing whatever
the [__] you know we don't like it
either that's what happens like in
Hawaii like people go to Hawaii and they
treat Hawaii like it's just another
state but really they got their whole
culture language history it's a
different Beast out there so is that why
they don't like they don't want people
coming there cuz that's why it kept me
from Hawaii they'd be like don't come
here even though I really want to you
know what it is about Hawaii tourism and
what I'm finding out from a lot of
friends who are locals I have a store
out in like w and stuff and you know a
lot of my longtime friends are in Hawaii
they don't it's not like tourism is an
issue per se because I think a lot of
the jobs are based around tourism when
tourism dies and not a lot of money
comes into this it's just how it is even
if it's [__] up and how they've kind
of been destabilized like that that's
what the situation is the problem is
like when people go and they just treat
the place like trash Hawaiian people are
very connected to the land right they
are so connected to the land they see
trash they pick it up off the floor
right you're you're on a beach you see a
plastic thing Start Tumbling to the to
the ocean you'll see everybody come up
and grab that [__] out it's not
something that's very typical that we
see of like American culture so
sometimes when we go to Hawaii people
forget yeah it's one of the 50 states
but not [__] really
you know we had a lay over there for
coming back from Japan I like this is
beautiful I really want to even the uh
like in B same thing like they
don't it's it's a big sense of community
out there right and that's what I think
America is missed just just Community
like we were driving past a wedding that
was going on and he was like if we
didn't have uh like stuff on our
itinerary we could have stopped at the
at the wedding because they love they
love everybody to celebrate the love oh
wow yeah he was he was like we could
have we could have stopped in there and
and then he asked us about nursing homes
he's said we would never put our we stay
our parents stay with us when they that
AG if they can't take care of then they
Community the never put them in a home
or anything like family the values you
learn from these other places like
America has no Co like even the food
that you think of is not our food pizza
hamburgers what people think is Amer
it's not our food comes from other
places too so yeah so I'm saying like
America is just like an amalgamation of
things like our culture is like a
Melting Pot right so that's why like
cultural identity is very we're country
identity so when somebody says I love
America that definition changes
throughout every person right when
somebody says like in Korea like tan
mingle which is like you know your
Korean Pride everybody has the same
sense of that right so they kind of feel
that thing we're we're very divided also
two our country is [__] huge you know
California to Texas two those can be two
different countries absolutely
absolutely yeah way [__] different
when I went to I like there's a big ass
[__] State Texas is a country and
it's so true what you said about people
different experience you say if I love
America cuz when I look at someone
hanging American FL like what you so
prideful cuz that hasn't been M what's
that mean buddy what you mean budy like
I don't know if I want to knock on that
door for but that was like during like
all this time where people were talking
it was a big conversation in the last
few years is like how did it become to a
point where somebody would put an
American flag and it became something of
like oh I don't know how this person
feels about crazy that was so trip I
didn't even think about it like that it
shouldn't be like that cuz this over
like this could be this could be an
amazing and play it could be because
it's opportunities here it's like
entertainment here but it's just like n
yeah like American valleys too are very
interesting with like family like like
you mentioned right like for us my
grandpa lived with us till he was 97
years old right and my mom had to change
his diapers they all this other stuff
that's not even her father that's my
dad's father but my mom took up that
mantle to take care of him like we had
to put my grandma into a hospice care
because she was getting fed through a
tube so we literally couldn't take care
of so but even for her we couldn't even
pull the plug even though we probably
should have because you got to kill
family you to see that so like I I I
definitely do see this whole thing of
like like even like Asian families right
let's say I don't know if I was living
in Sacramento I would probably still be
living with my parents until I saved
more money they're not charging me
they're not asking me for rent they're
paying for food they're doing all this
other stuff but you know conversing
myself some other American familyes like
oh when it's 18 I'm out yeah and Asian
parents are like well if you want to buy
home come live with us and just stay
here we had it all backwards and I saw
that in my family too so like my Grandad
he recently passed this year but before
he passed when I went home for uh the
last Thanksgiving like me and my brother
had to pick him up take him to then my
mom and her sister they're changing his
diaper and washing them and I was just
like that whole time I'm like this is
crazy like you put your family in a home
and him not be able to live his last
years around love but I also told my
parents like y'all need to start eating
better cuz this whole changing diaper
thing I don't know if I want to do that
I'm glad you mentioned that [__] I put
them on better now like y'all got to cuz
my my dad my granddad on my dad's side
is my last grandparent he's 93 still
walking still driving and it's about
moving and way eating just like and my
granddad on my mom's side he just stop
moving and then you stop moving you lose
it yeah so it's like I got them like
y'all work that's the thing too like
listen cuz you know I lost a lot of
weight right and it was it was a health
thing right it wasn't it wasn't like
self-esteem issues or whatever I just
had heartburn and diarrhea every day I
thought that was like
normal [__] was a baby they
diarrhea every
day you have the symptoms that every
medicine says you'll have if you like
people will be talking to me and they're
like I have solid shits I was like you
should probably get that checked
out that supposed to come out as liquid
y'all didn't know you probably get this
checked
out you got a whole to come out you
talking about comes out in one piece
what's the sound it makes was the
sound like hear like people [__]
cartoons I'm like that's not accurate
yeah so what did they say was the issue
for me being
fat I gave him the alley too yeah like
what was the what was causing only
heartburn and diar way I eat so let me
tell you how I would eat like so the
first thing I had to do was track my
food right and I don't I'm like counting
calories I don't know what what's going
right and so one day I calculated the
food and I had to do it over a week and
it would be up and down but at the
highest I would be EA like 5,000 Cal a
day and I didn't even [__] know cuz I
would just wake up and just start eating
and everybody wants to eat you know
money's good so I'm like I'm going just
go eat well I told the story on the
podcast before I found out I was fat
because of my wife I didn't know I
thought I was chubby so he'll tell you
how he found out I told you I told you
you yeah cuz you don't know you and cam
always as he how do you know he showed
me the picture what you mean you tell
you don't know you're inside of your
brain I'm looking at you like you you
you you obese what you mean you don't
know you what the problem is is like
when you're funny you can get you can
get anything doesn't matter our rules
don't apply to us so I'm sitting and
then we're you know if you've heard this
story I don't give a [__] so we're
sitting and then I'm eating food this is
true story not even a [__] joke and
there's this fat couple sitting next to
us right and I look at my wife
girlfriend at the time I was like look
at those fat people she stops and she
looks at me and I'm like you're fatter
than them I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about I'm not fatter than them
she goes are you kidding I was like are
you kidding and we start getting a
little argument I'm like I'm fatter than
them I didn't know I was way fatter than
that and so I go home the funny thing
you didn't tell is that they listen to
this whole time you cut back to them the
camera and they're like that fat guy is
weird what talk so I go home and it's
like in my head the whole time I'm like
am I [__] fat like how fat am I so
you know and it went through like a
whole process of a a couple months of me
accepting that I'm a fat person like I
got like I wore my shirts and they were
like double XL I that's because you know
this is a French cut shirt you know so
it just just be [__] up a French
Bridge what what what age is this is
that a French Bridge what age is this
this is like 207 28 and so then I
started blaming like the dryer right I'm
like the dryer's [__] up my clothes
so it get so I went through this whole
process and it got to a point where I
started walking down the stairs and my
titties were jiggling I started feeling
things yeah the the last [__] straw I
was playing
basketball I Tred to cross somebody up
the [__] ball moved but my body
stayed and it
just gone and I'm like hold on a second
am I a fat person got on the scale it
said 290 I was like damn my [__]
scale is
broken was
inal gymnastics and then you know I
finally had this moment where I was like
okay I think I'm miserable you know none
of this is [__] normal then I started
losing the weight and now it's hard to
go back it's yeah can't you know what
that feel like and you know how your
body you feel so light now you feel like
you can move around it's weird like your
body knows what it wants oh yeah
absolutely tell them though how you
found out yeah I went to the doctor and
with my mom I'm sorry tell the age to so
I as him his age yeah that was about
like 14 13 14 that was fat as [__] uh I
went to the went to the doctor and
that's my call ID
picture
such such a friend he look like Queen
Latif shut it off I do I look like I I
look like a little lesbian full Butch it
look crazy getting the doctor and uh the
doctor like you know they go through all
the checkups they wait and everything he
was like well you know yes your son is
borderline obese I start
crying that's my favorite part of the
story The Dr roast I I start crying cuz
like in my mind I was like I'm going to
die like this this is it cuz I as a kid
you see people talk about obese and it's
like they got red flags around like
obese so when he when he said that I was
like I'm I'm obese he was like yeah
border line OB beast but with some
things we could do to take care of it
I'm like I guess I just got to stop
eating I just went on a run I was like
I'm not we would go to hotels as family
vacation I wouldn't take the elevator I
would go up the steps I don't care if we
was on the 30th floor damn you were
dedicated I was I wasn't playing I was
like I'm not doing this I was like I'm
not doing and that that bleeds over to
my discipline to day so I had it young
but I didn't know that activated it [__]
that so funny goes you're OB
bees lock in get it together but I mean
crazy I even had a doct like our family
doctor at the time would tell me I was
fat but I just I just wouldn't believe
it you know what I mean cuz she was like
Indian too she had a very thick internet
she was super [__] cool cuz you you
just watch your whole life she like
remember she was like you have to lose
weight and I'm like why she was like I
was like well what does like the blood
test say it's like everything is
perfectly fine but you are very fat I'm
like so but you're say I'm okay though
yeah skip all that and I would just
block everything that she says like all
this stuff like heart disease I'm like n
you said I was fine though the blood
work came out fine and I'm good but when
you get older all that [__] catches
that's what people don't realize that
people just say oh you going to die
anyway I'm like look you don't want to
spend the last 20 years of life in and
out the hospital terrible that's just
not the life you want to live so at
least granted things can happen that's
fine but maybe try to prevent a little
bit like let me let me ask you this if
you guys when you guys talk to health
with about health with your parents is
that [__] hella frustrating yeah of
course at first at first I think they
starting they like it was but now more
information is out and my parents
recently went to the doctor and they
told them they got to stop eating so
much rice and he needed to and my dad's
a Bahamian man that's rice is part of a
Caribbean diet so yeah they they started
doing that and my dad's like me he can
give up anything cold turkey like we
want to stop we can stop don't have
addictive person that just stop so he
hasn't been eating it my mom recently
called me she was like we're getting
groceries I'm about to go to see them
for the holidays she like uh my dad was
like my dad called me he said my mom
want to know am I eating rice I like
absolutely I'm I'm in good shape I'm
eating rice I want rice I know you doing
you y'all not eating but I'm my parents
are so [__] annoying my dad's
annoying right cuz he he lost a lot of
weight recently but R listeners wow this
podcast is brought to you by mintmobile
my friends ooh mint mobile my friends
I'm telling you right now you don't want
to miss out on this deal because I can't
think of a better gift than turning an
overpriced r bill into just $15 a month
with mintmobile dude mint Mobile's best
offer of the year is here for a limited
time buy any 3month plan and get 3
months for free by selling online and
limiting the traditional cost of retail
mint mobile passes significant savings
on to you think about all the money you
can save my friend stop wasting it away
I know these groceries are expensive out
in these streets guess what you gotta
you gotta you don't have to just save
money and then lose out on a great
Mobile plan that's where mint mobile
comes in my friends and I'm telling you
it's amazing for a limited time by any
three-month mintmobile plan and get
three months free by going to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com
genius5 new customers only additional
taxes fees and restrictions apply see
mintmobile for details he was getting
like the daad belly or whatever he's
been skinny his whole life but when you
become pre-diabetic you have to be very
careful about high carbs High sugars so
I come to the house and I found out he
was pretty diabetic and I go to the
house I'm like hey why the [__] is there
so much ice cream in the freezer right
he goes I don't eat that I'm like then
why'd you buy it he goes I don't know I
didn't buy it I'm like listen here you
dumbass who the [__] else lives here you
know I'm getting pissed right I'm like
don't he goes I didn't eat the ice cream
you could check it it's there's no
there's not a single spoon out of I open
half of is gone I'm
like not a sing [__] kill somebody
dog I'm like is he [__] is he [__]
with me right now idiot yeah he think
I'm dumb he's like you'll open it right
he was like trying to Bluff he's like
trying to [__] around he's like go ahead
open it see what happens open it half it
was gone I'm like that's crazy cuz I
opened up four of
them four of them all half they're all
half all four of them you can't even
make a [__] Choice yeah yeah so I go
to
bed and I wake up at night and I hear
some somebody walking around and I come
outside I see my dad and I [__] you
[__] not he's like moving moving
around a little bit and he gets up like
a [__] a vampire like this mhm I just
watch him goes into the freezer and
starts eating ice cream out of the thing
he sleepwalking I don't know so I asked
him the next day this is a grown ass man
by the way I I saw you eat ice cream
last night you told me you don't eat ice
cream he goes that wasn't me no that's
you're the only other person here I like
I'll sock you right I'll [__] sock
you right now and he's like tell me this
with a straight [__] face and so I
have to get my mom involved I'm like why
are you guys buying ice cream yeah you
got you can't bring that [__] he was
like I keep telling him not to bite but
he keeps he goes he says that he's not
eating the ice cream my mom [__]
flips out she comes out she goes are you
lying to people now he goes I'm not
eating it I'm like dog this is crazy
like you're
sticking he too deep too deep yeah he
loves [__] my dad too always have ice
cream and like coconut cookies after
dinner so he had to he had to stop that
too but my dad he he he can just give it
up so good it's addictive like you know
like I said yeah we both don't have
addictive person we both stop drinking
like all this so it yeah this is not a
beer this is water y'all liquid desert
wait so you guys don't drink alcohol at
all anymore October made two years for
what did it was 75 hard we did 75 hard
so that year like I lost four family
like back to back it was just I was like
so mentally I was just like I wasn't
like depressed but I was just lower than
I usually am I like I need something to
mentally mentally get me back and when
he brought 75 hard to me it is a mental
thing so you can't drink while you're
doing that so after that I felt so good
that I like it's not going back cuz you
know the older you get alcohol the last
hangover I had I threw up six times the
next day so I was like I'm I'm good I
had a bad hangover last October 1st
after that I'm never again I'm done
stopped well I don't I don't drink that
much anyways I'm going to I don't have
alcohol in my house so I drink with
people right so I that was me too I
wasn't a big drinker already so it was
easy I think like what I like Tim likes
to drink a lot and I I'll drink too
right but I never get drunk because the
the repercussions of getting crazy drunk
is just not worth it it bleeds over like
three days yeah you just like you're
you're [__] up mentally you're [__]
up you're exhausted you're tired like
the moment is great right but if I could
have a fun moment without drinking I'mma
I'm going do that right but like Korean
culture too it's like you have to
[__] drink and it'll be so exhausting
sometimes especially when you do like
meetings and stuff with other Korean
people they look at you like you [__]
killed people and murdered and pillaged
if you don't [__] drink alcohol they
look at you like you're dumb like you're
an idiot and so I I started doing this
thing where I would take a shot and I
would Chase it but I would just spit the
alcohol into the cup because it got
ridiculous cuz I mean I'm talking about
they're drinking like I would say like
15 20 shots in a night and I'm like I
can't do it like I just physically can't
it's the one poison that people look at
you crazy for not yeah [__]
drink this poison and I think at this
age your body just just it just reacts
differently like even if I go out now I
need 3 Days To recover I'm such a
homebody like I go out I'm down for
three days like I need to rec we went
out Saturday to go uh visit see a friend
DJ the next day I felt like I had a hang
I didn't drink I drunk water I said why
am I feel like I'm drunk like what is
going on when I'm forced to go to like
club events I always hate it cuz my
voice gets super [__] up cuz I'm
always trying to talk super loud and it
stresses me out cuz the next day I'm
just I'm just ashy vocal all day the
your
shirts I should like the kbo dude the
next day hello I [__] hate it yeah
it's just you you can't help but to
start changing as you see stuff as you
feel your body you're just like all
right another thing about traveling you
learn yeah yeah yeah you just you just
learn you like I think I'm you be
surprised like how I think what I like
too about other countries like you see
people walk a lot yeah you know what I
mean like every morning I walk 5 miles
walking walking yeah so I wake up 8:30
a.m. and I'd walk 5 miles I have this
route that I do just to start my day and
then I go about cuz in case I don't work
out at least I got this year you know
and it helps out cuz I still have bad
eating habits like I you it's just like
sometimes I see them golden arches no no
I just like [__] that stop that See Asia
I gave up I gave up fast food too cuz I
felt so good with no processed stuff I
don't even eat the whole menu there's
only three things I eat there fileo fish
oh my oh David chicken nuggets and then
the soft serve those are the only three
things I eat there I can't even be mad
at soft serve
s is a dollar and it is I can't be mad
at soft but the but I gave up fast food
too man like I'm like we've been
pescarian 10 years now so it's just like
damn you guys don't even need any beef
or nothing nothing so if we're traveling
if it's something like like wagu I tried
a small Jaan or when we went to sagol I
always heard how like you never hear
beef described as fresh that's not a
thing you describe beef but people like
is this a different so I try a piece of
a burger and I was like that [__] was
phenomenal it was weird it was crazy but
like a whole do something like that not
no pork nothing like that but I'll try
something very small but yeah no no beef
no pork people love pork that's like our
main protein there's like we do a whole
documentary on that [__] that's how much
we love that [__] and I used to love
Korean barbecue before we became I used
to love going let's Grill it up you know
it's a different concept though from
like uh like westernized versions of
what protein is compared to everybody
else
like the protein is actually not that
big it's mainly carbohydrates and
vegetables and all other sh and then the
protein kind of like flavors everything
but now like in Korea because because
it's becoming more westernized you're
seeing a lot more fatter people there so
fast food has infiltrated big meat
portions it wasn't like that before so a
lot of fermented dishes and soups and
stews that's like a majority of Korean
food actually so like the the Western
night creeps and even I saw this
documentary where they were doing the
case study of what westernized food does
to the the rest of the world and then
Chinese China's obesity went up by 300%
within a year right because the all the
extra protein with a high carb diet the
plates are this big yeah yeah that's
what always stress me out when I'm out
in Japan I'm like oh this is a normal
human portion this woman and we see you
see different things like you'll see
eggs on the Shelf in other countries
they're not in like refrigerat it's just
on the shelf and it's like maybe I would
eat meat if I lived in a different
country that didn't put all cuz a lot of
stuff in our food is illegal in other
countries which is insane that's crazy
maybe I would cuz it's safer and cleaner
but here I know dude the egg in Japan it
was like a dozen and they don't even
have to label it like farm fresh eggs it
just is what it is I cracked open the
egg it's like this golden yolk and it's
and the the Dozen of Eggs was a170 or
something you know I'm saying like yo
this is crazy I would have to spend $12
to get a carton of this their regular
eggs it's nothing special it was just
like in a random Supermarket right there
$170 and it was just delicious the eggs
over there are so fresh when you crack
them they already
scrambled are eating them
way than that's crazy it's it's it's
just a different vibe out there man like
damn I want to [__] go back people
man travel man reading icky guy that's
like iy Guy books reading and studying
that so it's just like once you start
feeling better I feel like you guys have
been on this like journey in the last
like I would say six or seven years of a
lot of like self-improvement absolutely
and like what what kind of what kind of
started that Journey because I feel uh a
lot of people don't do that right we
kind of just like Coast through life and
then whatever comes comes but then to be
very active about becoming a better
person takes a lot of like energy and
effort to do it so what made you guys
start that though I know for me I know
the exact point is um cuz you know we
moved to Cali in 2013 and when we moved
there we were just in an apartment and
then we moved to a house the following
year and I just remember going there I
was like I don't want a TV in my room
and I want to read as many books as I
can in that year to improve I just I
just did that and the first two books I
read was Four Agreements and The
Alchemist and them two books changed my
life like The Four Agreements changed my
mindset then The Alchemist has changed
the way I just look at the world and
then after that I changed my eating
habits and it's just ever since then I
just been once you start feeling good
and things change you don't want to go
back like what am I going back to I'm
going back to where it wasn't as good so
mentally it's been and then we become I
guess I guess we call ourselves
self-improvement junkies now I'm always
TR
find it could be Aries thing we like be
challenged but once you start feeling
good and you see how your life change
because of it it's just you can't go
back and the pandemic too had a lot of
time to sit with myself and so it's like
started reading even more during the
pandemic then realizing like yo like our
main purpose is like to master ourselves
so that we can serve the world better
because I can't do I can't take anything
with me so what I can leave is a better
impression on one two three four five
whoever people I mean many people I can
you know leave a good impression on like
and so we could like we recently found
our purpose like what's funny like a
month ago it's funny you say I think it
finally aligned but but yeah so we
realize like we just like to raise other
people's vibrations like we like coming
in the room we we realize that's our
superpower like we get opportunities
just off of the energy that we give
other people and that comes from working
on yourself I didn't work on myself I
can't give that off to other people and
so you know we just living in this zone
of high frequency which is the new brand
that we're about to be launching it's
called high frequency H ye frequency swe
was one of the little which is which is
stands uh was for your third eye so
that's what we call high frequency but
we just realize like that's it's easier
to Li it's easier to have a brand when
you're living the lifestyle already oh
for sure so I'm like we already doing
that everything we doing is high
frequency anyway and that's the vibe we
want to give off the people and it kind
of just simple life to be honest like I
don't need a lot I just want to I want
to create and give that energy back to
people and hopefully they go and do
something you know I mean that's the
thing too right like I feel you know we
lived such a high-paced life for such a
long time that when you kind of stop and
slow things down you get to really pick
apart the things that aren't important
anymore right and then you just take it
and you throw it away and you don't need
to look back I think the hard part for a
lot of young people is that you guys
live a life of comparison too much and
the thing that you guys never get to
realize until you're older or it's too
late is that you're going to die like
you don't think about that your
mortality really starts to put things in
perspective it's like okay like I I'll
say this too one of the worst habits
that people have is that you have people
in your circle you just had them around
just because they were there but they
need to earn their place in your life
everybody you know what I'm saying so
like they'll bring like this person that
they don't like and like oh they've
always been in the group just let them
hang here why why they shouldn't be here
like if they [__] up everything they're
draining you yeah take them out and like
that's the thing too like that's where I
think it's very smart it's like okay let
me just figure out where my place is and
then this is the goal and I'm going to
stick to it and whoever attaches to it
that's and I'm too old for that like if
I'm if I'm around someone and I feel bad
every time I leave them you don't need
to be in my life but if I come around
someone and I always feel good after
that's why we rock with you like you
call us we coming always say yeah few we
definitely everything we I'm an energy
guy like I just go by energy and if you
just bring negativity around me I'm too
old I don't like drama I didn't deal
with drama in high school so why I'm
going deal with it as a grown man don't
make sense to me people just love
negativity I watch what I watch to watch
what I consume I be watching like the
Love and& Hip Hops and be I don't know
anything about blueface and I don't even
know how to pronounce the girl name I'd
be trying to stay away from it like
that's the hard part too I I I really
agree with that is like sometimes when I
have to do podcast I have to talk about
these hot topics and then I talk about
it and as I talk about it and I'm
researching my brain starts to melt it's
just like yo like the whole like I
haven't done a podcast on the uh the
blueface and uh right it's just cuz
watching that [__] makes me feel like a
bad person become judgy can't help but
the judges and I'm glad you brought that
up cuz a lot of people don't know this I
almost was thinking about stepping away
from our pod because it's a lot of hot
topics and it was one point I was like I
was in a Zone where I was watching
everything I consume and I was like I
don't know if I can do this because a
lot of things they want us to talk about
is the stuff I don't want to watch yeah
and then you know people will suggest
certain oh did you hear about this this
is like I don't want to talk about this
because there's a couple of things right
I don't ever feel good about this number
two I don't [__] know and so I'm just
going to keep my mouth shut and observe
and then learn because so a lot of
people now it's like how media is it's
not about knowing things and being
correct it's about who gets to say it
first yeah and I dislike it so [__]
much another thing like with social
media I always tell people why are you
arguing on social media because to no
one wants to be wrong in the public ey
so even if you're right they're not
going to admit that you're right so you
it's a endless argument that's going
keep going on forever without any
conclusion so tell people like criticism
doesn't bother me I only care about
people I care about of course they say
but someone a stranger I don't know cuz
most of the time any of that criticism
they said to you I've never had someone
say it to my face and not in like I'm
trying to fight somebody but no one
comes up to you in your face and tells
you these these things that they tell
you when they're hiding behind a screen
so why does it put so much weight on
your life and you let it affect you yeah
oh 100% even like a really good good
advice that I got from somebody was like
negative and positive comments are both
bad because you're still dictating how
you behave and the things that you do
based on what other people say so just
don't read it at all yeah like even if
they say something great or nice about
you guess what that opinion can change
the next day like that read it like
Japan no no no no no unless you're the
Japanese hamster that's what I call your
sexual assault person the Japanese
hamster jaanese hster until someone like
you want a million
yeah yeah but I think it's just a it's a
part of growth man and it's just like am
I going to live the rest of my life not
getting better that don't make sense to
me so let me just get better now and
live the most fullest fulfilled life
that I can live and that at least people
can be like you know
what he enjoyed you know what I'm saying
like and this type of connection is
really smart too especially like the
stuff that you guys have all built
because a lot of the times people will
do something where they'll connect with
people through negativity right so
they'll find a common enemy and then you
guys will just talk [__] about that
person all [__] day and then guess
what that enemy will disappear when they
then what are you left with you're left
with no connection there was no bond
here right like all that hateful [__]
stays at hateful [__] nothing grows from
it it's it's ferti as soil nothing will
grow from this and so like sometimes
like you I'll do a pod because I'm
roasting people this is what we do we
roast and they go I [__] hate that I
actually don't hate that person like I
think you guys got something Twisted
here we're just we're making jokes you
know what I mean if they are not
involved in the joke then they don't get
made fun of whatever you know yeah and
I'm a firm believer that certain
blessings come on certain frequencies so
that's why I'm always trying to raise it
or stay at a certain place cuz it's like
I realize when I am in a space where I'm
like doing everything watching while
consuming eating right I just start
getting blessing like when I did 75 hard
so many blessings and opportunities came
out of nowhere from from doing this like
this travel thing like I would getting
checks out of nowhere that this out of
random like oh this is residual for
something and I was like every time I'm
in this space good things happen so why
wouldn't I try to stay there it's also
like that power of like like positivity
might Church you look for they'll can
always out negative things in your life
and if that's all you focus on that's
all you will see think about it I know
this is a stupid comparison but like you
know when you just buy a new car right
and then all of a sudden you see your
car everywh it's the same [__] you
become very aware of the stuff that you
put your time and attention into and so
like one of the things that kind of gets
on my nerds with some people is just
like they always say I have bad luck
it's like you don't have bad luck I say
have bad luck as joke right you don't
have bad luck bad things happen and you
place your focus on this so much there's
so many great things that happen right I
said it probably is a church thing that
I grew up with right it's like that idea
of always looking for the opportunities
in life and kind of just be being very
grateful and the graciousness will take
you super [__] far super far it's
hard it's hard to be it's hard to be
upset when you're grateful yeah it's
hard to be upset when you are writing
down the things you're grating for
grateful for when you're around people
that practice gratitude like it's like
you know what I ain't really nothing to
be upset about like this and this is
what I like about being an adult too cuz
I remember when I was in high school if
I said the word Grateful people assume
I'm gay immediately like y remember back
when I didn't say gay I said I said
grateful yo back in the day if you said
anything positive like [__] gay dog
I'm like damn like come on bro that's
why it's part of my morning routine like
my morning routine I write 10 things I'm
grateful for and what's funny like say
you wake up in a bad mood or this low
energy by time I get through my routine
I'm good and like I live my life where
I'll try something and if it works for
me it works for me like it's been things
I tried like that ain't really for me
but I I encourage anyone just just try
it and if it fits in your life and for
your mind and your body your spiritual
your mental do it and that's what my
routine does for me so like certain
things I do it it sets my day it sets
the tone for my day because I feel like
that first five minutes so important
like is most people you can choose to be
happy but a lot of people just let that
one bad thing happen and it takes out
and you know before we end too I learned
that from my mom it was like my mom
always told me she was like I I don't
ever want to hear you complain about
work because no matter how poor we were
when we grew up I've never went to work
hating my job and I looked back and I
was like oh that's right I never heard
her say I hate working at the store she
never did and we went through some tough
[__] she was like it was just grateful
cuz I can make a living I could feed you
guys even though we didn't have a lot
this is more than other people have so
like don't don't ever wake up in the
morning thinking that you don't have
enough like you always have more than
you need it's just like if you live a
life of comparison this you'll never
ever have enough it's always looking at
somebody else's Pockets right what is
this person have what ises this person
who the [__] cares that's why they say
it's the thief of Joy
comparison real thing I heard I know we
about to get out realest thing I heard
was uh they're talking about how we pray
for strength uh from God we pray for
strength but uh we we get upset when the
training comes and I was like that's
real because like you pray for strength
but then like when the thing comes
that's testing the strength you're like
what you doing you're like well you pray
for this how you get strength you can't
say hey trainer I need you to train me
to get strong and show it to the gym why
the [__] you training
me well You' be like me sometimes God
gives you signals about how fat you
are there we go [__] block no no no
he didn't give you signals he sent you a
seal even the seal was like hey he tried
every way like he like David look God
told me hey I'm trying to let you know
like are you
serious he like I need the translation
app he's not understanding me I went up
to see I was like hey say he just goes
fat oh [__] well guys uh promote that
yes yes yes uh high frequency um I'm I'm
pretty I'm pretty sure it'll be out when
this comes out high frequency.com you
can grab your
cange we got Embrace Mantra yes our
Embrace series and the Mantra reads We
Believe to create change in the world
you must create change within so if you
want to create change within and embrace
change tap in with us man and uh the
shorts a part of it too shorts a part of
it uh we we we want you to actually when
you wear it feel like you know what it's
a reminder every time like something bad
happened let me embrace the chain some
you going through a healing issue let me
embrace healing let me embrace joy and
we hope that it can help somebody out so
I love that stuff also remember once
again Shady Side Up uh Shady Side Up the
best way to uh support your favorite
content creators is to kind of buy and
support the things that they create so
uh check them out obviously dorm tment
uh you guys have the comedy Trap House
trap house yeah we have boss Talk
podcast boss talk Y and then yeah Shady
Side Up high frequency just working cool
we'll check it all out genius print
every Sundays at 12:00 p.m. we'll see
yall next time peace